hello and welcome to this video playing
m-town 19 1951 okay so we get a mirach C
point I lost the last game with that
opening here in the video that was a
real bummer
now here black has a couple of most
castles d6 energy form I think that g4
is quite interesting and he does that it
is not played often but it is a quite
quite interesting line he five now was
recommended by Raja Papa Giovanni
probably not pronouncing it right in his
hyperaccelerated dragon book with some
interesting analysis it is a fairly non
typical position for my Roxy point okay
yeah this is not as critical
hmm maybe I actually had c5 may be here
at c5 preventing him I don't know okay I
just played a normal move Bishop d7 yeah
I can do all the standard things him a
six is a little bit odd to be honest 95
could have thought about 95 one move
early actually okay I would like to go
95 in this position to use the weekend
to be six square preparing it with route
D 1 so that 95 Queen takes rook takes
can be played I had a head c5 again I
keep missing the idea of c5 somehow and
again I can play c5 yeah now I think I
will do it right maybe he has some thing
like rook da it takes but should be six
or so it it cannot be brilliant either
and he takes a just really
yeah this is a similar idea to what I
what I described to play Luke g8 him no
it just doesn't do it okay so if I take
these six here is that somehow bad 26
[Music]
don't see why I shouldn't do it
just wind upon their 96
yeah I've got basically everything
nicely covered you can try something
like Bishop c3 here and prep a - well
maybe this is relatively best but it's
so not something that is very enjoyable
to play so how do we do that rook chinks
[Music]
I have rook a1 now
covered each other and go from here I
own the rock c7 it's not something you
can kind of an offer you you cannot
refuse mmm yeah at the time situation
was really and was really an issue as
well he was spending so much time so
here here the most interesting choice as
d5 which is a very unbalanced position
white can try and with 95 or something
with 95 2295 for example or just develop
it's an interesting position
yeah after 96 we get a fairly normal
Muraki see by and position and this was
something that I was interested in but
maybe he can go b6 yeah yeah yeah well
okay we should be to is fairly normal or
this looks fairly standard is 6 here 95s
maybe interesting already but there's b2
was hanging and I wasn't entirely
certain about the situation here it
looks good for white but yeah I rather
wanted to keep more material on the
board up to you one look a B aid and now
c5 is coming and should be good
it's quite a nice advantage this is also
not bad I think but I okay Queenie -
didn't think about that okay yeah well
c5 is very principled this and now he
should play rook to da de think I was
thinking 95 yeah and the engine so green
yeah one point is what I saw it said
this is a tactic so he cannot take with
the rook on d6 and if he takes with the
pawn I mean that must be good for white
in some way Bishop g5 okay they get him
yeah he took with the pawn and then I
can grab the 825 and Bishop h6 haha you
know during the game I thought the only
thing that is kind of off is that this
bishop is this is Dyke is this kind of
situation is a little bit technically if
he and he has Bishop h6 I didn't you see
during the game but I had this hunch
that there is something now I probably
have to move the rock here and then the
engine wants to take him well yeah that
would have saved him probably here and
this is very nice for what
okay rook g8 was strong enough and I
just have a pool of laughter with the
bishop am but yeah this is help young
winning winning the night for nothing he
cannot go I have six at this particular
moment and this of course doesn't help
either he should play b5 I guess and
then let's say should be four looks very
normal
[Music]
the bishop he is very strong in this
position okay thanks for watching